اخبار العالمي بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم كتائب القسام تقول انها
اوقعت قوه اسرائيليه من 30 جنديا بين قتيل
وجريح بعد استدراجهم لمنزل ثم تفجيره
مشيره الى انها قتلت خمسه جنود اخرين شرق
خان يونس والجيش الاسرائيلي يقول ان 28
عسكريا اصيبوا في معارك غزه خلال الساعات
ال 24 الماضيه تجدون المزيد من اخبار حرب
غزه في رابط بالتعليق الاول باكستان تعلن
تنفيذ ضربات عسكريه ضد مسلحين مناهضين لها
داخل ايران وذلك بعد يومين من تنفيذ طهران
ضربات في باكستان طهران تدين الهجوم
وتطالب اسلام بات بتوضيح سريح اما الرئيس
الباكستاني فقد اشاد بما سماها مهنيه
القوات المسلحه في تجنيب المواطنين
الايرانيين اصابات حسب قوله مضيفا ان
باكستان وايران دولتان شقيقتان ويجب حل
القضايا بينهما
بالحوار وكاله الطاقه الدوليه ترفع مجددا
توقعاتها لنمو الطلب العالمي على النفط في
عام 2024 بمقدار مليون و2 الف برميل يوميا
وذلك بالاستناد الى تحسن النمو الاقتصادي
العالمي وانخفاض اسعار الخام اضافه الى
توسع الصين في قطاع البتروكيماويات
في احدث مساعيها لتحدي ابل سامسونج تكشف
عن سلسله هواتفها الجديده جلاكسي اس 24
المزوده بوظائف الذكاء الاصطناعي المتعدده
كالترجمة
ه